je penche du côté du rassemblement les
français détestent la division et j'ai
bon espoir qu'on arrive à les faire
travailler ensemble
en tout cas c'est aussi pour ça que je
suis là le vrai pour l'unité pourquoi
parce que quand c'est difficile pour les
français et qui voit des politiques qui
se divise et qui s'opposent les uns les
autres c'est insupportable pour eux
comptent sur votre portefeuille ça va
pas bien et que vous voyez des élus qui
sont plus préoccupés à se diviser qu'à
travailler sur le terrain c'est
insupportable donc ce que j'essaye aussi
c'est le rassembler toute notre famille
tranquillement sereinement
comment faire pour rassembler les
républicains en corse
et c'est moi faire et vous verrez qu'on
va trouver le bon chemin je connais un
peu l'île je connais les tempéraments
c'est mieux une île où on a des gens qui
ont du tempérament politique en corse on
a la chance d'avoir des élus qui ont du
tempérament et de l'énergie tant mieux
[Musique]